we're on problem 103
103 and it says if n and k are greater
than zero so both n and k
are greater than zero
is n over k an integer
n over k
an integer so essentially they're asking
is k divisible into n
so let's see statement one
says
n and k are both
integers n
and k
both integers and that's good that they
told me that because i was assuming it
incorrectly
so they're saying n and k are both
integers well that still doesn't help me
much n could be 2 and k could be 100 and
2 over 100 is 1 over 50 that's not an
integer although n could be 4 and k
could be 2 and that would be an integer
4 over 2 is 2. so statement 1 by itself
doesn't help me
statement 2 says
n squared and k squared are both
integers
n squared
and k squared
both integers
well once again i don't see this as
helping me much
right if n and k are both integers of
course when you square them they're
going to be integers you take any
integer and you square it you get an
integer you take any other integer and
you square you get an integer so
this is actually this gives me no
no new inter information relative to one
so i'm just trying to see if i'm missing
something but as far as i can tell it's
e both statements together are not
sufficient to answer this question
right i mean i can give you a case
n could be 4
n could be 4 k could be 2
and then
n over k would be an integer but then
and both of these would satisfy both of
these conditions or it could be 2 and 4.
in which case n over k could aren't
integers they don't actually
differentiate between n and k at all
yeah so it's e
next problem
104.
if the average arithmetic mean of six
numbers is 75 how many of the numbers
are equal to 75
excuse me
okay so six numbers are equal to 75 how
many of them are equal to 75
okay equal to 75 is the question
let me go scroll down a little bit
the first statement
says
none of the six numbers is
less than 75
so none
less
than
75
so this is interesting if i have six
numbers and their average is 75 and none
of them are less than 75
well they essentially all have to be 75
and
let's let's
let me let me write down a new i mean
it's it let me write down if i let's say
the first number
is 75
now let's just say that i had some
number above 75 in the list let's just
say for argument that there was a 76 in
the list it doesn't have to be an
integer they're not assuming that but
let's say i had 76 in the list in order
for it the average to be 75 i would have
to offset this number that's one more
than 75 with another number that's one
less than 75
but they told us that none of the
numbers are less than 75 so i can't so
if i have a number greater than 75 i
have to have a corresponding number less
than 75 or several of them to wait to to
balance off that number or you could
have several balancing several it can
get complicated but the general idea is
is that if no numbers are less than 75
you can't have any numbers greater than
75 either so this actually tells you
that all six
all six
are seventy-five
so statement one alone is sufficient
statement two says
none of the six numbers is greater than
seventy-five so
none greater than 75 well it's the same
argument
if i have a number if if i have some
number let's call it a
let's say it's one of the numbers
that's in my list and it's greater than
75 in order to average down to 75 i'm
going to have to have or let's say a is
a is less than 75 right because we're
using statement number two if a is less
than 75 let's say 75 is here in the
number line i'm just
doing ad hoc diagrams so a is less than
75 in order for the whole group to
average a 75 i have to have some number
that's bigger than 75 to balance off the
ace and we call that b but they're
saying that we have no numbers greater
than 75 so if we have no numbers greater
than 75 we can't have any numbers less
than 75 either and all the numbers have
to be equal to 75 all six of them so
once again two is also sufficient so
each of these statements independently
are sufficient to answer this question
actually they both answer the question
that all six are equal to seventy five
that was interesting
seventy what am i doing i am on problem
105
105
is the absolute value of x
equal to
y
minus z
okay absolute value of x equal to y
minus z
all right so statement number one
they tell us
that x
plus y
is equal
to z
x plus y is equal to z so let's see if
we can do some substitution z is equal
to x plus y
so if we substitute
z into this top equation we get the
absolute value of x is equal to y
minus x plus y minus x
plus y
so that means that the absolute value of
x is equal to
y minus x
minus y
and that says that the absolute value of
x is equal to minus x because the y's
cancel out
well i don't know if this is true still
this would this would apply to any
negative number right if i have a
negative 1 here negative 1 absolute
value is 1 and negative negative 1 is 1
as well so this would apply if x is 0 or
some negative number but they don't tell
us that so we don't know if this is true
statement 2
tells us well there you go statement 2
tells us that x is less than 0.
so if this tells us x is definitely a
negative number and if you put any
negative number into this
which we got from this condition and
this condition
if you put this into that you know this
is true for any negative number right
the absolute value of any negative
number is the opposite of that number so
you need both of these statements and
obviously statement two alone is useless
because if you just say x is less than
zero you don't know anything about y or
z without this condition right here
so both statements together are
sufficient but individually they're
reasonably
useless 106.
we're getting up there
106.
what was the total amount of revenue
that a theater received from the sale of
400 tickets
some of which were sold at x percent of
full price and the rest of which were
sold at full price so sale of 4 400
tickets so let's say
we have the reduced price tickets and
the full price so
r is the number of reduced price tickets
and f is the number of full price
tickets so r
plus f so the total number of sick
tickets was 400
what was the total amount of revenue and
then the total amount of revenue
generated
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to
the price
of full price times the full price
tickets
so p times
f where p is the price of full priced
plus the number of reduced tickets
and that's sold at x percent
of the full price tickets
okay so whatever x is x percent we'll
convert it to a decimal at the
appropriate time so this is what did the
the initial problem description tells us
that the total number of tickets is 400
and then whatever oh it's x percentage
of p
so whatever the full price is times the
full price tickets plus this would be
the reduced price times the reduced
price tickets equals the total revenue
now let's see if we can figure this one
out
x is equal to 50
x is equal to 50. well this by itself
just tells us that this is p over 2
right here this x is 0.5 right it's 50
percent remember they said x percent so
this just makes
this equation it turns it into
0.5 times
p times
r
plus p
times f is equal to
the revenue
and we still have one two three unknowns
and two equations so that by itself
isn't enough all right we have that p
we actually have four unknowns r p f and
revenue four unknowns two equations not
good enough
two
full price tickets sold for twenty
dollars each so the price of a full
price ticket is 20
so now this is interesting now we could
take this
and substitute it into this equation
because we now know what the price is
the p variable
and so if we use both of these
conditions we have 50 percent of a full
price well that's ten dollars times the
number of reduced price tickets plus
twenty dollars
times the number of full price tickets
is equal to
is equal to
the revenue generated
and then they and then we know that a
total of 400 tickets are sold
are oh sorry r plus f is equal to 400.
well even now we still just don't have
enough information if they had just told
us they would have to tell us
you know either r or f or they would
have to tell us the total amount of
revenue generated in order for us well
actually that's what they want to figure
out they want to know the total amount
of revenue so in order to figure that
out we would have to
yeah we would have to have at least one
more condition to solve for r
and then be able to solve for f we have
to know rf to figure out the revenue let
me just make sure i'm not missing
something here
yeah there's no other way to just you
can't just separate out an r plus f so
i'm going to say that e both statements
together are not sufficient if i have to
go back and
yeah i think i'm pretty sure i'm right i
don't think i'm missing anything right
here
some of which were sold at x percent of
full price the rest was sold at full
price which is 20
yeah so r plus f is 40. and then we have
10 r plus is equal to revenue yeah we
don't we have three unknowns and two
equations two linear equations not good
enough next problem
oh i'm overtime see in the next video